welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilshire host and today our
guest is Professor David blight the
class of 1954 professor of history at
Yale University professor blight is the
director of the Gilder Lehrman Center
for the Study of slavery and abolition
at the Macmillan Center he has written
numerous books on race and American
history and lectures widely on Frederick
Douglass and W EB do-boy and problems in
public history and American historical
memory today we will be talking with
Professor blight about his newest book a
slave no more two men who escaped to
freedom including their own narratives
of emancipation
welcome professor blade Thank You moon
delighted to do this thank you a slave
no more is remarkable in that it marks
the discovery of two new emancipation
stories tell us how you came by them
well it was one of those scholars dreams
I never planned to write this book these
two rare autobiographies by former
slaves almost literally fell into my lap
the first authored by John Washington
was brought to me by a literary agent
who was working on behalf of the
manuscripts owner the second manuscript
authored by Wallace Turnage came to my
attention within the same six months
independently from the Greenwich
Connecticut Historical Society I was
invited there to give a lecture and
while there the director said that her
staff believed they had an authentic
slave narrative and would I have a look
at at that one and the truth is I hadn't
paid enough attention even to the first
jet because it was at a moment in my
life when I was moving to Yale this was
five years ago but when I sat down with
the two of them I realized what I
were to post-civil war autobiographies
by former slaves and their stories are
largely about how they escaped from
slavery in the midst of the Civil War
and they're quite rare documents we
don't have very many of these yeah my
understanding is it's basically just a
handful of emancipation stories well
there are really two parts of the genre
of slave narratives there's the pre
Civil War genre from roughly about 1745
until the end of the American Civil War
we have approximately sixty-five
autobiographical treatments by former
slaves published in English but from the
end of the Civil War until about the
1920s when the last of American slaves
were dying off who wrote about
themselves we have only about 55 and
some of these are quite short that
Rakhal um's and newspapers one of them
is very famous Booker T Washington's
book called up from slavery in 1901 but
what makes these two documents so
extraordinary is that these had never
been published they had never been
through any kind of editing or filtering
process and they arrived in my lap as
raw pieces of writing in one of the two
cases possibly never seen by anyone
except the author's closest family
members and even in the other case it
hadn't been seen by anyone beyond family
members except possibly a few people so
they arrived without anyone having
touched them and my challenge then was
to decide what to do with them what I
simply published them and write an
introduction or would I try to uncover
the lives of these heretofore unknown
seemingly ordinary American slaves and
nevertheless one in 1873 and the other
undated but probably in the 1880s sat
down
and decided to write up their story
especially the story of their
emancipation so I did indeed ultimately
publish them in this book but I also
with the help of a tremendous
genealogist at the New York Public
Library Christine McKay was able to
locate enough and in some cases a lot of
documentation particularly about their
post-war lives so that I was able in the
end to try to write in effect a kind of
dual biography of two otherwise
heretofore unknown American slaves and
to write a book that is essentially
about the process the story of how
emancipation of four million slaves
actually happened in the midst of the
chaos and disorder of the civil war
let's talk about the actual journals
themselves what did they look like you
know were they pieces of paper wasn't a
bound and was it difficult to decipher
at all the writing it was not difficult
to decipher the writing and it was
actually not difficult to authenticate
them that actually was the easy part in
the case of John Washington his
manuscript survived and his family it
survived actually with a granddaughter
who lived to be quite elderly in the
1970s her name was Evelyn Washington
easterly and she was living in
Massachusetts but before she could do
anything with it she died but she had
left it to a very close friend a woman
named Alice Jackson Stewart and mrs.
Stewart worked with the manuscript and
collected a lot of documentation
including fabulous family photographs
but she too became elderly and in the
1980s she died and she left the
manuscript to her son
who
an african-american retired judge in
Boston his name is Julian Huston and
he's now the owner of the manuscript in
Washington's case he wrote it on
essentially loose paper in the other
case Wallace Turnage he actually wrote
it in a leather-bound stationery book
that he bought at a stationery shop in
lower Manhattan because it still has the
insignia of a shop on it
his survives and an even more
extraordinary way it was preserved by
his daughter he had three surviving
children and his daughter whose name was
Lydia Turnage Connolly lived to be 99
years old she died in Greenwich
Connecticut in 1984 having moved there
because she married and an Irish
immigrant labor named Tom Connolly she
worked as a maid in a hotel and he is a
porter they were poor but when she died
she had one friend left in the world she
died in a nursing home in 1984 she had
one friend left
an elderly woman named go out Gladys
watt well mrs. watt it turns out kept
one box of material from her friend for
18 years until one day in 2003 she
watched a public television documentary
called Unchained memories which is a
film about the WPA oral history
narratives done in the Great Depression
she watched that film and as the people
at the Greenwich Historical Society tell
it it was almost literally the next day
she called them up he said I may have
something that would interest you they
sent someone out and indeed she did what
she simply had was one box and in that
box was and is a black clamshell box
clamshell in the sense that it has a top
that you take on and off into which this
narrative fits perfectly excuse me and
he wrote it as I said blue line paper in
this stationary book it's as though his
daughter was
serving it either as such a precious
thing or possibly because she was hiding
it because we do know now that Lydia was
passing for white she explained her tan
complexion according to her surviving
friend by saying she was Portuguese now
I don't know exactly why she preserved
it that way but it was beautifully
preserved and the only other thing in
the Box were five photographs for them
of Wallace Turnage all of which he had
taken as a good working-class guy would
in studios in New York City from
somewhere in the 1880s until probably
the latest one about 1910 and then one
photograph of Lydia herself the daughter
this is all we had to go on in Wallis
turn ages case when we started to
research his life five photos and the
narrative but through senses manuscript
City directors bank records church
records a lot of newspaper research and
a lot of other material we were able
able to uncover not only a fair amount
about his life as a slave but also of
his post-war life and in Wallis turn in
his case he lived until 1916 as a common
laborer in New York City married three
times two wives died he had seven
children three of whom lived to
adulthood and in John Washington's case
he lived till 1918 he and his wife Annie
lived most of their adult lives in
Washington DC they had five sons and as
I said it was through the daughter of
his youngest son that this manuscript
survived let's talk about John
Washington and Wallis Turnage the two
gentlemen whose narratives you came john
Washington was born in Fredericksburg
Virginia in 1838 his father was a white
man though he never named him if he knew
who his father was he didn't tell us in
fact the greatest frustration and my
research on this
that I have never been able to determine
his paternity nor even how he got the
name Washington won speculation I have
is that he made it up that if you're in
central Virginia you be a Washington why
not do lots of them he grows up in a
town largely a city Fredericksburg
Virginia his mother by the way was a
slave woman named Sarah who was literate
and taught him his first alphabet and
his first letters in that sense he was a
very lucky guy he's very talented he's
skilled he's highly valued by his owner
by the 1850s when he was a teenager they
began to hire him out which was a
relatively common practice especially in
urban slavery he was hired up to do odd
jobs he was often hired off for a year
at a time at one point he was hired out
to a tobacco factory where he said he
actually really enjoyed the routine of
the work in part because he got to learn
all the black work songs he also fell in
love he felt crazy in love because among
the documents that have survived with
John Washington are extraordinarily rare
love letters and fragments of a diary
and most of that diary is actually about
his courtship of a young free black
woman named Annie Gordon whom he will
later marry now he bided his time and
John's escape came at the very first
arrival of the Union Army on the
Rappahannock River in Fredericksburg in
April of 1862 he describes an
extraordinary scene he's working at a
hotel in Fredericksburg called the
Shakespeare and he was again a highly
valued worker he was it was sort of a
steward the owner would give him the
payroll to pay off the the slaves who
took the money home to their masters but
at that moment all the white people are
evacuating Fredericksburg and he
describes taking the dozen or so black
workers up on the roof of the hotel
where they could see across the river
and he said they could see the gleam of
the yang
bayonets and then he brought all of his
fellow black workers down into the
kitchen and he poured a round of drinks
and then he held a toast with his fellow
slave workers and the toast he said was
to the Yankees and then he simply walked
down to the river he witnessed the
formal surrender of Fredericksburg and
then he tells us he walked approximately
a mile upriver in the direction he said
of the sound of a union band and then he
crossed the river he said at Ficklin
mill and the old stone ruins of that
mill is still there so I know exactly
where he crossed and he was liberated
after getting out of his rowboat by a
captain in the 21st New York volunteers
and he said at the moment they told him
he could be free if he wished to he said
he thanked God out loud and laughed and
then John Washington had spent the rest
of that summer of 1862 as a camp and a
servant and and for quite a bit of it as
a mess cook for the Union Army all over
Northern Virginia and he dates his
arrival in Washington DC as part of the
first big wave of freedmen into the
capital as September 1st 1862
frustratingly his narrative though ends
that fall the last line in his narrative
is a sentence about his wages
he says I'm working two jobs one is
bottling liquor and the other is working
on the wharves and I make a dollar 25 a
week those were his last words in the
narrative and of course you want to grab
him at that point and say no don't stop
who are you where did you go what
happened to you
I first found a shred of evidence of him
a good shred in late 1863 in a directory
he's living on 19th Street in Washington
DC at an address that is today
Constitution Hall about two and a half
blocks southwest of the White House
and at that point he had his wife Annie
their newborn child his mother Sarah and
his 68 year old grandmother Molly living
with him exactly how he got them out of
Virginia I don't know because he didn't
tell us now in well it's Turnage this
case his escaped if anything is even
more dramatic he was born on a little
tobacco farm in North Carolina and
there's snow hill and he too had a white
father and a slave mother his mother's
name was Courtney he knew exactly who
his father was his father's name was
Sylvester Brown Turnage and and wallets
named his father on every document the
rest of his life as though he was saying
I know who my father was but he was sold
at the age of 14 by his indebted owner
to a Richmond Virginia slave trader and
thankfully Wallace names a lot of names
and places and dates in his narrative
because it really helped me out in
finding him he was owned for about six
months by the largest slave trader in
Richmond his name was Hector Davis he
lived in a three-story slave jail for
from the winter to late spring of 1860
there was preparing slaves and what was
called the dressing room to take them
out to the auction floor and one day he
was simply told the boy you're in the
auction and he was sold to an Alabama
cotton planter named James Chalmers in
72 hours later he found himself on a
huge cotton operation near Pickens Ville
Alabama which is right on the
Mississippi border and Central West
Alabama most of Turnage is narrative
after that is the story of his five
attempts during the civil war to escape
the first four of which were over into
Mississippi and northward where he was
trying to make it to the Union Army
which controlled northern Mississippi by
1862 and then finally his frustrated
master who kept coming after him and
retrieving him
got fed up and he took him down to
Mobile Alabama in the summer of 1863 and
sold him at the mobile slave jail
auction house for $2,000 he was 17 years
old and he lived the next roughly 15
months as the slave of a merchant and
mobile again he named that merchant
Collier minge which was good help to me
in figuring out his life in mobile and
one day he was he was driving his
master's carriage would have been late
July of 64 and he crashed the carriage
harness broke the carriage broke the
horse got away he went home and his
master and his mistress were so angry at
him that they really punished him they
took him down to the slave jail and
ordered 30 lashes for him with these the
worst contraption they used to beat
slaves they stripped him naked and
strung him up on a bar on the wall and
at the end of these 30 lashes he was
standing there bleeding and his master
said walk home but instead of walking
home Wallis simply walked out of mobile
he walked right through the roughly
10,000 Confederate troops who were
encamped all around mobile and then the
rest of his narrative is the
extraordinary story of his three-week
about 27 mile trek down the western
shore of Mobile Bay through a colossal
swamp it's called the follower of our
estuary today he traversed three rivers
a huge swamp and finally he reached the
mouth of out at the mouth of Mobile Bay
and he describes himself barely alive
he'd been half starved for days on him
but he said one day he prayed especially
hard and the tide brought in an old
rowboat he tipped over the rowboat
grabbed a plank of wood he said and he
began to row out into Mobile Bay and
then comes his most dramatic moment of
his narrow
you can almost feel him on the page
trying to capture that moment he
describes how a wave is about to capsize
his boat and then he said.he her doors
and the oars he heard were a Union
gunboat and then that gunboat were about
eight sailors they told him to jump in
and he did and as Wallace sat down in
their boat according to his testimony he
said the Yankee sailors looked at me and
they were struck silent and I don't
doubt they were they then rode him to a
Sand Island fort that clothed it fed him
put him in a town overnight the first
acts of kindness he'd ever experienced
from white people in his seventeen years
and then the next day they they wrote
him over to Dauphin Island which is the
huge big sandbar island at the mouth of
Mobile Bay and there in Fort Gaines in
late August of 1864 and that old fort is
still there he was interrogated by the
Union commanding general of the entire
region a man named Gordon Granger
probably because he was an escaped slave
from mobile and they wanted intelligence
and in that interrogation Granger gave
him simply two choices he could join a
black regiment that they were organizing
or he could become a servant to a white
officer and Wallace chose to be the
servant you never told us why but I have
a good speculation on that he probably
felt that he had simply suffered enough
and he was choosing a kind of security
he then served out the rest of the war
as the mess cook for a captain in a
Maryland regiment whose name was Junius
Turner he is with that regiment when it
captured mobile in April of 65 he was
with that regiment guarding Confederate
prisoners in New Orleans after the war
and he was with that regiment as they
traveled across the United States and
were mustered out in Baltimore in August
of 1865 Turnage then lived about three
years in Baltimore and then
I began to find evidence of him and the
first marvelous evidence I found was the
1870 census and I found him living with
his mother and his four half siblings in
the 300 block of Thompson Street in what
we today called Greenwich Village which
was then known as little Africa it was a
community of about 2,000 former slaves
who had moved to New York City and it
was in New York City or across the river
for part of it in Jersey City where
Wallace lived out the rest of his life
as a drayman bartender at one point he
called himself a glassblower and he
worked as a night watchman he worked in
all kinds of common labor jobs but as I
said he also went to a studio and had
his photograph taken four times he also
joined the Abyssinian Baptist Church the
most famous black church in New York and
he joined a black fraternal order called
the Hamilton Lodge of Oddfellows
and he is buried in the collective
burial plot of that fraternity in
Cypress Hill Cemetery in Brooklyn so
this is the saga of these two men and
briefs one escaping as you can see in a
town early in the war even before the
Emancipation Proclamation the others
escaping to the Union Navy later in the
war under very different circumstances
and what it allowed me to do through
these two windows on emancipation is to
tell the story both in microcosm and
macrocosm of how emancipation actually
came about for hundreds of thousands of
American slaves before the war ended one
in one in this case to the Union Navy
and one to the Union Army so how long
did it take you to pull together all of
this information how long was the
writing of the book how long did it take
you I suppose it took me about three
years from start to finish
accumulating the information it was
frustrating at times trying to find them
the big holes in their lives that
couldn't complete as in the case of John
Washington's father but we just kept
looking and kept looking and then I
decided ultimately that I wanted this to
be a sort of dual biography I was
particularly interested in telling their
post-war lives the best I could I wanted
to be able to say something through
their stories of what actually happened
to some of of American slaves who became
free in the war lived in cities in some
cases migrated north became part of the
first generation of an urban black
working-class developed families joined
churches weren't fraternal orders and
John Washington's case was president of
the black sunday-school Union in
Washington for ten years and I found
enough information a remarkable amount
of information that I was able to do
that I also found out a lot about their
children and what happened to them the
kinds of lives they lived and quite
remarkably by continuing to dig and dig
and dig in obituaries we also finally
found a living descendant we knew there
was no likelihood of living descendants
in a case of Wallace Turnage because all
three of his children died childless but
we knew it was a good chance with John
Washington and by details I will spare
you approximately a year ago we found
the living granddaughter
John Washington she was then 89 she's
not 90 years old her name is Ruth
Washington now we found her through on
the bitumen and she lives today in a
retirement trailer park village in tampa
florida and about a year ago right now I
had the out-of-body experience of
calling a nearly 90 year old woman one
night to tell her I was about to publish
the autobiography of her grandfather the
remarkable thing was that she knew
absolutely nothing about her grandfather
which was not unusual for
african-american families at the turn of
the 20th century and into the early 20th
century her father was John Washington
jr. but her grandfather the author of
the document died the year she was born
and she's told me now many times that
her father never talked about the past
she had no knowledge whatsoever that her
grandparents had ever been slaves and
she had never even met them her
grandmother lived about nine years after
she was born and never met her but we've
had this remarkable experience now of
being able to show her her a big part of
her family's history and I've even had
her at now two public events with me
where she speaks along with men even
signs of the books with me and I suppose
a lesson in that is that one should
never say never and also that the past
especially this past in America our past
was slavery the Civil War emancipation
and it's aftermath is not that far back
there we have living grandchildren some
of those living grandchildren are this
week next week
facing a chance to vote for an
african-american for president and in
some ways I can't wait to call up Ruth
and ask her what it felt like
Wow remarkable stories thank you so much
for being here with us today and sharing
your research with us well thank you
Marilyn I enjoyed it for more
information about Professor blight and
of course his new book a slave no more
please visit our website at yale.edu
backslash Macmillan report be sure to
join us again next week for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale